Who do you trust more about COVID?
A legendary rock star or
the world's most popular podcaster?
The biggest takeaway from the latest
culture war battle is that you get
to decide.
Neil Young pulled his music from
Spotify, but you can still listen to
his discography easily enough.
And even if the world's most popular
streaming service had dropped Joe
Rogan, he'd still have all sorts
of ways to reach his massive
audience. The scandal du jour
reminds us that radical free speech
is alive and well.
In a profound way, it doesn't
matter if somebody somewhere wants
to block it, because it'll be
available just a few clicks away.
No matter what, Young fired the
first shots by telling the streaming
service Spotify that they had to
choose between keeping his music on
its platform or continuing to
host Rogan's podcast.
Young says Rogan spreads dangerous
misinformation about COVID.
Spotify updated its rules
about publishing content that
promotes dangerous, false or
deceptive medical information about
COVID 19 and other diseases.
But it stood squarely by
its marquee star, whose contract
is worth more than a reported $100
million. Young also immediately
inked a deal with satellite radio
provider Sirius, and his music
remains widely available on YouTube,
Apple Music and his own website.
Same goes for Joni Mitchell, who
quickly followed suit.
Rogan also keeps rolling on
telling listeners via Instagram
that the whole point of his show
is to have interesting conversations
and let people come to their own
conclusions.
If I pissed you off, I'm sorry.
And if you enjoy the podcast,
thank you. Young's call for Spotify
to boot Rogen is risible,
but his decision to pull his music
is worth celebrating as an assertion
of his right not to do business
with an entity that offends.
Cancel culture is a real concern,
but its impact is limited by
the limitless nature of how easily
stuff gets made and distributed
these days. Our world of cultural
plenty was simply
unimaginable in 1966,
when Neil Young cut his first album
with Buffalo Springfield.
Back then, there were a handful of
major record labels a few movie
studios, three national TV networks,
and only AM and FM radio
gatekeepers actually had a lot
of power to suppress speech they
didn't approve of.
Nowadays, even the mighty
Spotify is just one streaming
service among many.
The problem isn't that our choices
are too restricted.
It's figuring out how to triage,
what to read, watch and listen to,
because there just aren't enough
hours in the day to take in all
the amazing movies, shows, songs,
books and podcasts available.
We get to decide what
and when we're going to watch and
who we're going to trust, which is a
great outcome, but one
we should never take for granted.